Queen Lion of the animal kingdom is looking
to improve her democracy. She recently allowed
citizens to elect representatives to the Jungle
Council which governs the kingdom.
However, she recognizes that her citizens
are not happy with the voting system. Let’s
watch an election on one of the small islands
of her Kingdom to see why:
On this island there are three political parties:
the two big ones: Kea and Tuatara, and a small
third party, Kakapo.
On election day, the citizens each cast one
vote for a local candidate they want to represent
the range they live in. The results are as
follows:
With the average across the island that Tuatara
gets 49%, Kea gets 48% and Kakapo gets 3%.
The election is run using First Past the Post,
meaning that candidate with the most votes
wins. Because Tuatara got the most votes in
each range, they get to control 100% of the
seats on the council.
And this is why so many citizens are unhappy.
The majority of them, the 51% who voted for
other parties, get no representation on the
council at all.
This seems unfair to Queen Lion but she’s
not sure how to fix it. The citizens like
having local representatives and don’t want
to change the range boundaries.
But luckily Kiwi, one of the citizens of this
island, has a suggestion for Queen Lion on
how she can make the system better while keeping
local representation and leaving the ranges
as they are.
The idea is called Mixed Member Proportional
or MMP and it makes two changes: the number
of seats on the council is doubled and each
citizen gets two votes, not one.
Here’s how it works:
At first, election day for Kiwi is just the
same as before.
He gets a list of candidates running to represent
his local range on the council. Kiwi picks
one and the winner will be the candidate with
the most votes.
So far the system is no better – Tuatara
again wins all the local elections and still
more than half of the citizens don’t have
any representation. But here’s how Kiwi’s
second vote – and those extra seats on the
council – fix this.
Kiwi uses his second vote to pick his favorite
political party.
These second votes are tallied up and show
the percentage of support that each of the
political parties has among the citizens as
a whole and reveals how imbalanced the council
is so far.
To fix this imbalance, members of the political
parties are added, one at a time, to make
the council more proportional.
Tuatara is the most over-represented and Kea
the most underrepresented, so Kea gets the
first empty seat.
This continues, adding one Kea at a time until
both Turatara and Kea are over-represented
and Kakapo is under-represented, so they get
the final seat.
Now, the jungle council represents, as close
as possible, the actual preferences of the
citizens – which is a huge improvement over
the old, first past the post method.
There is, however, one interesting question
that should arise at this point:
Exactly who decides which members of the parties
get those extra seats?
The way it works is that, before the election,
the political parties make a list of their
favorite candidates in the order that they
want them to get on the council.
So, if there is only get one extra seat, the
name at the top of their list is chosen. If
they get two seats, the first two are chosen,
and so on.
This makes MMP a bit different from other
voting methods in that it makes political
parties an official part of the way the election
works.
This may give the party leaders greater control
over their members because they can reward
or punish their actions by changing their
placement on the party list.
While this may be a disadvantage of MMP there
are a number of other benefits that Queen
Lion, in particular, likes.
Because fewer votes are wasted, it mostly
Eliminates Gerrymandering and prevents minority
rule.
It also gives more choice to the citizens
by encouraging political diversity.
This point is worth expanding on.
Notice how, with MMP, the percentage of votes
for the local representatives isn’t the
same as for the parties. This is because in
the local elections, citizens have to vote
strategically.
For example, Kakapo voters don’t like Tuatara
at all, but they can tolerate Kea. Since there
are so few Kakapo voters they know that their
candidate doesn’t have a chance of winning
the local election, so it’s really a race
between the two big parties. Thus many of
the Kakapo will vote Kea in the hope that
he might win and be their representative.
However, when it comes to voting for their
favorite political party, this strategy doesn’t
matter. The more votes a party gets the more
representatives it has on the council.
So citizens are free to vote for smaller parties
they like like knowing that every vote counts.
Queen Lion reviews her options and decides
to switch her Kingdom to MMP. Now, for the
first time, the Jungle Council is a true reflection
of what her citizens want.